good morning hickets tuesday in mid-2019
on our podcast dear hank and john i said
and i'm quoting myself directly here we
all must prepare ourselves for the
global disease pandemic we all know is
coming
the year before on the podcast 10 things
that scare me i listed as one of my
chief fears of global disease pandemic
in fact i predicted the pandemic so many
times from podcasts to essays to crash
course that if i were more famous
conspiracy theorists would probably
conclude i had some kind of inside
knowledge which i suppose
i did in the sense that i read a lot of
history from the great dying in the
americas to the black death in eurasia
infectious disease has long been a
central force in human history and not
just ancient history i was four years
old when the united states recorded its
first aids-related death
since then tens of millions of people
have died of aids-related illnesses
mostly in impoverished communities where
people were denied access to
antiretroviral therapy
for decades we shouldn't be surprised by
something as historically routine as
pandemics
what we should be is prepared i'm
thinking about this because i just read
melinda and bill gates's annual letter i
recommend reading it link in the doobly
do because it articulates some stuff
about kovid that i hadn't seen written
so clearly before like one of the points
it makes is that for too long we've used
the phrase global health to refer mostly
to
impoverished countries the kind of
places we associate with vulnerability
to infectious disease
but as we have lately learned one
infectious disease is a threat to
everyone
and two the fact that infectious disease
is a greater threat to the most
vulnerable and marginalized among us
does not mean that we should spend
less time and money fighting those
diseases it means we should spend
more time and money fighting those
diseases we need to think of global
health differently now as a shared
worldwide effort to improve the health
of all humans through openly exchanging
resources and expertise
and this will require truly global
cooperation because as the gatesletter
says in a global crisis like this one
you don't want companies making
decisions driven by a profit motive or
governments making decisions with the
narrow goal of protecting
only their citizens so what does a
post-pandemic model of global health
look like well we need a global
alert system so that we can identify new
pathogens quickly but for that to work
well
people need to be able to access health
care so that their illnesses can be
diagnosed and treated in a safe
sanitary and adequately staffed facility
we also need to invest in vaccine
development as the gates letter points
out if this pandemic had occurred in
2010 it would have been
much much worse because we've made so
much progress with vaccines in the last
decade but we need to accelerate that
progress
and we need to address the underlying
inequities that have long
driven the spread of infectious disease
i mean almost 700 years
ago a chronicler of the black death in
england wrote virtually none of the
lords and great men died in this
pestilence
disease does not treat people equally
because our social orders do not treat
people equally and if we don't address
unequal access to health care pandemics
will continue to be routine and they
will continue to disproportionately harm
the most vulnerable among us
the gateswater argues that pandemic
preparedness needs to be taken as
seriously as we take the threat of war
and that made me think about how we've
long placed war at the center of our
historical narratives
you know we learn about this empire
taking on that one and the causes of
this war and how that war was won
we learn much less about disease even
when it's deeply connected to war as in
the spanish flu of 1918 or more recent
cholera outbreaks in yemen i think this
sidelining of illness used to make a
kind of sense because history was seen
as the story of human choices and
disease did not feel like a choice
but now while we certainly don't control
infectious disease we do have quite a
lot of choice around it i mean we chose
to eliminate smallpox we also choose to
accept a world where on average the
poorest people die
30 years before the richest people we
won't choose whether the next novel
disease pandemic emerges but we will
choose how ready we are
and how quickly and equitably we respond
which is why
stronger and more equitable healthcare
systems is on my 2021 vision board hank
i will see you on friday